we wouldn't be able to discuss this  right now no on YouTube at all it  wouldn't be allowed and this is why  there's a problem with YouTube  this relationship between YouTube and  Crowder has been heating up some Stephen  Crowder host of the show that is uh  currently banned on YouTube  we had a million subscribers on Rumble  oh thank you this is the most watched  live stream ever of all time that's not  been broadcast on YouTube not Cloud but  it's viewers are linked together in  their cause  Free Speech Stephen Crowder kicked off  of YouTube well guess what Stephen  Crowder last night was also trending  Robert was Crowder got banned from  YouTube last night they were to go on  there and actually set a new record on  Rubble I think they had over 3 million  viewers you remember that you can have a  powerful Voice without traditional  mainstream Tech